i do love the science fiction of greg
egan this new australian science fiction
writer and his
novels tend to
more cosmic themes and but his short
stories
are just one
scenario after another of these
medical near-term medical
dilemmas that could involve
quite ordinary people and this is all
with easily extrapolatable
medical technology that we see taking
shape all around us
if you take the leap into more wild-eyed
speculation
then you have the possibility of
and this is fully explored in greg
gigan's fiction as well
the possibility of digitizing
human experience actually
downloading consciousness out of
bodies and into machines
well everybody says well that's a
horrible idea i wouldn't
have that done to me well would you
if you were 24 hours away from death
if that were the option if they were
saying you know we're either going to
pull
the plug or we're going to download you
and then pull the plug
check which box you would prefer
how many people would say well i don't
know i've always been skeptical about
this download business but
hey at this point why not
well then but the strange thing is
digitizing
a digital existence is
may turn out to be an eternity of
experience
we operate at 100 hertz
sitting here 100 cycles a second
that's about how the rate at which your
body mind system works
the pc sitting on the desk comes
now if it's a good one with two 400
megahertz
processors in it what what is that
80 000 times
more events can be packed by that
computer into a second
then you can pack into a second
uh 10 an hour inside that computer
is like 80 000 hours outside
the computer so right at the brink of
death
you can suddenly opt for a strange
new kind of eternal existence
not that different from being born
i mean it involves a machine of course
but maybe biological death will be
something
for mennonites and the amish and
every all the rest of us will opt for of
course
digital existence and but then of course
you know there have to be insurance
policies to make sure your disk isn't
erased and
the electricity keeps running and nobody
rewrites your
code and nobody overwrites your code
and uh yes they would have to be
very careful and then the question
is you know whose obligation after a few
hundred years
whose obligation is it to keep these
digital ghosts
alive uh is it society's obligation
after your
fortune has long been run out and your
relatives have forgotten you
and you're still romping through the
virtual
fields of elysium who of course
maybe there's you can do useful work in
there and be
paid and deposit that salary into the
account
which keeps the machine running which
it's all comes down to money isn't that
weird very interesting
i mean it's it's all money you know
how much life you can buy how many
indulgences
your tithing can procure for you it's
all
paying off somebody as
william burroughs said it's all some
kind of a
racket which doesn't mean you want to
throw down your cards and stomp off into
the dark because it's the only
racket in town so you have to be very
careful about rejecting
[Music]
you